dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr karol jonay fahir
virtual reality vr in short is maturing
at a rapid pace
and its promise is truly incredible if
one day
it comes to fruition doctors could be
trained to perform surgery
in a virtual environment we could train
pilots with better flight simulators
teach astronauts to deal with zero
gravity simulations
you name it and you will see that with
today's paper
we are able to visit nearly any place
from afar
now to be able to do anything in a
virtual world
we have to put on a head-mounted display
that can tell the orientation of our
head
and often hands at all times
so what can we do with this oh boy a
great deal
for instance we can type on a virtual
keyboard
or implement all kinds of virtual user
interfaces
that we can interact with we can also
organize imaginary boxes
and of course we can't leave out the
two-minute papers favorite
going into a physics simulation and
playing with it
with our own hands in this previous work
hand-hand interactions did not work too
well which was addressed
one more paper down the line which
absolutely nailed the solution
this follow-up work would look at our
hands in challenging
hand-hand interactions and could deal
with deformations
lots of self-contact and self-occlusion
take a look at this footage and
look interestingly they also recorded
the real hand model
with gloves on we might think what a
curious design decision
what could that be for well what you see
here
is not a pair of gloves what you see
here is the reconstruction of the hand
by this follow-up paper absolute
witchcraft now as you see we can
manipulate objects
or even wash our hands in virtual
reality
this is all great when we play in a
computer game
because the entire world around us was
previously modeled
so we can look and go anywhere anytime
but what about operating in the real
world
what if we wish to look at a historic
landmark from before
well in this case someone needs to
capture a 360 degree photo of it
because we can't turn our head around
and look behind
things and this is what today's paper
will be about
this new paper is called omni photos and
it helps us produce
this 360 view synthesis and when we put
on
that head mounted display we can really
get a good feel of a remote place
a group photo or an important family
festivity
so clearly the value proposition is
excellent
but we have two questions one
what do we have to do for it flailing
yes we need to be flailing you see
we need to attach a consumer 360 camera
to a selfie stick
and start flailing for about 10 seconds
like this this is a crazy idea
because now we created a ton of raw data
roughly what you see here so this is a
deluge of information
and the algorithm needs to crystallize
all this mass
into a proper 360 photograph
what is even more difficult here is that
this flailing will almost
never create a perfect circle trajectory
so the algorithm first
has to estimate the exact camera
positions
and view directions and hold on to your
papers
because the entirety of this work is
handcrafted
no machine learning is inside and the
result is a quite general technique
or in other words it works on a wide
variety of real-world scenes
you see a good selection of those here
excellent our second question is this is
of course not the first method published
in this area
so how does it relate to previous
techniques
is it really better well let's see for
ourselves
previous methods either suffered from
not allowing too much motion
or the other ones that give us more
freedom to move around
did it by introducing quite a bit of
warping
into the outputs and now let's see if
the new method
improves upon that oh yeah
a great deal look we have the advantages
of both methods
we can move around freely and
additionally
there is much less warping than here now
of course not even this new technique is
perfect if you look behind the building
you see that the warping hasn't been
completely eliminated
but it is a big step ahead of the
previous paper
when we look at some more side-by-side
comparisons one more bonus question
what about memory consumption well it
eats
over a gigabyte of memory that is
typically
not too much of a problem for desktop
computers but we might need a little
optimization
if we wish to do these computations on a
mobile device
and now comes the best part you can
browse these omni photos online
through the link in the video
description and even the source code
and a windows based demo is available
that works
with and without a vr headset try it out
and let me know in the comments how it
went so
with that we can create these beautiful
omni photos
cheaply and efficiently and navigate the
real world
as if it were a computer game what a
time to be alive
what you see here is a report for a
previous paper that we covered in this
series which was made by
weights and biases weights and biases
provides tools to track your experiments
in your deep learning projects their
system is designed to save you a ton of
time
and money and it is actively used in
projects at prestigious labs
such as openai toyora research github
and more and the best part is that
weights and biases
is free for all individuals academics
and
open source projects it really is as
good as it gets
make sure to visit them through wnb.com
papers or just click the link in the
video description
and you can get a free demo today our
thanks to weights and biases for their
long-standing support
and for helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching and for your
generous support
and i see you next time